[Música]
juego piales ya está listo hablemos de
los deportes comenzamos con el caso de
violencia de género denunciado una de
una judoka francesa sierra vale son
cosas que venimos haciendo seguimiento
hablamos de ese caso de la judoca mago
pino campeona olímpica en los pasados
juegos de tokio quien denunció a su
pareja y antiguo entrenador alan smith
de haberla agredido el fin de semana
este jueves tanto mago como alan
ofrecieron sendas ruedas de prensa en
parís sean recordemos que la justicia
absolvió alan por falta de pruebas margo
entregó más detalles sobre ese ataque
que asegura ocurrió en el domicilio de
la pareja en la noche del sábado al
domingo de ese mago que alan había
bebido alcohol y rechaza la versión de
su pareja quien afirma que a ella le
disgustó que él fuera a partir a
trabajar a israel y a raíz de eso se
habría desatado una discusión que habría
terminado en ataques muchos esto dijeron
intenté detenerlo le dije a la detente
decente no me defendí no sabía en donde
estaban mis brazos no me defendí para
evitar los golpes sobre todo intenté
hacerlo entrar en razón
los
doctores estábamos en todas partes a la
derecha a la izquierda nos golpeamos
contra las paredes contra el radiador
luego nos golpeamos contra una puerta me
hizo caer sobre ella en otra habitación
nos levantamos nos golpeamos contra un
muro
-juan vamos a cambiar ahora deportes
hablemos del baloncesto la nba porque
hubo una paliza histórica en ese deporte
ese partido de que todo mundo está
hablando en la liga de baloncesto de
estados unidos 152 a 79 ese fue el
resultado de la victoria de día de noche
de los memphis grizzlies contra los
oklahoma city thunder un margen de 73
puntos la mayor diferencia registrada en
la historia de la liga una derrota
dolorosa en particular para el argentino
gabriel de quien jugó 22 minutos con los
thunder los wish les llegaron a ganar
por más un margen de 78 puntos también
la mayor diferencia que ha llegado a ver
en un encuentro de la n es además un
récord de puntos para la franquicia de
145 hasta anoche la mayor diferencia que
se había visto en la nba era de 68
puntos en una victoria de cleveland
sobre miami en
1991 que dicen desde los thunder
escuchamos a su entrenador después está
es la exposición que hay cuando compites
cuando compites estás expuesto a altos y
bajos en competición y la competición
viene con mucha alegría y también viene
con dolor frustración e ira en el
videojuego hubiéramos jugado usted y yo
y hubiéramos ganado el partido y salvado
y si no hubiera sido tantas ganas as
hablemos ahora de fútbol porque hay que
ampliar un brasil de ser atlético
mineiro que volvió a imponerse en el
brasileirao después de 50 años el
conjunto liderado por hulk es el nuevo
rey del campeonato brasileño y acaba con
la racha del flamengo que venía del
bicampeonato al atlético mineiro remontó
este jueves a bahía como visitante en el
estadio arena font innova los locales
ganaban por 2 a 0 a falta de menos de
media hora para el final del encuentro
mineiro reaccionó con tres goles en
cuatro minutos para quedarse con la
victoria y sellar el campeonato a falta
de dos jornadas para el final de la liga
y de brasil nos vamos a méxico porque el
torneo apertura- avanza en sus
semifinales a noche atlas golpeó primero
y ganó en casa de pumas el miércoles
tigres venció a club león por 2 a 1 la
vuelta de esas semifinales son el fin de
semana y ya conoceremos a los grandes
finalistas juan gracias por toda la
información deportiva feliz fin de
semana